[Music]
it's nashville's biggest night
e.t at the acms that's crazy
[Music]
i am at a ten of nervousness et's taking
over the acm awards
i didn't realize how much i'd missed
everybody for a night of history-making
moments
it feels good to be a part of that
history
and show-stopping performances i've
never played this song
i'm a little freaked out plus when we
first met country's biggest stars
i'm carrie underwood i am 21.
hey y'all this is thomas rick how's my
mo does my mullet look good
and blake shelton from then to now with
gwen
only on e.t this is et live's
countdown to the acm
tonight's the night the acm awards are
going
down in nashville and we got a sneak
peek at what to expect
starting with return host keith urban
and history maker nikki guys
i am at a 10 of nervousness
but i'm also like at peace i i still
can't believe that
i get this honor and i'm just so excited
and
and i don't take it for granted it's an
unusual environment right
i mean we have uh it's not like the
opera house is going to be full of
people
um but i think it just i mean getting to
play with
mickey last year i knew right away that
we could do
we could do this effortlessly together
in addition to his hosting duties
keith is also set to perform tumbleweed
i've never played this song i've never
played this song with my band
outside of the studio uh i'm
a little freaked out but at the same
time a bit giddy about getting in there
and figuring it out as well
the awards will take place at three
different iconic venues
the ryman the grand ole opry and the
bluebird cafe
a repeat from 2020 when the awards were
moved from vegas
to music city more than 30 songs will be
performed by over 25
artists including luke combs who has
three nominations this year
[Music]
the newlywed will perform his ballad
forever after all
he wrote for his wife nicole oh man i'm
excited you know i don't know about like
emotional you know i don't want to get
like weepy up there
you know what i mean because i still
gotta sing so hopefully that doesn't
happen we'll see though
former acm host dirks bentley will also
hit the stage
teaming up with husband and wife duo the
war and treaty
covering u2's pride in the name of love
hopefully be a big moment the show we'll
guess we'll find out but
i'm excited to see people think about it
they were the first african-american
married couple to perform on the acm
award so that's history
that's amazing the powerhouse
performance lineup
also includes kenny chesney and kelsey
ballerini
joining forces for the world debut of
half of my hometown
[Music]
[Applause]
and double the fun for the knoxville
native who will take the stage once more
with his band
i'm very excited you know we um in
rehearsal here i had i haven't seen my
band in two years
it was really emotional today i i didn't
realize how much i'd missed
everybody you know but when i saw them
it was um it was really good
so many performances that are going to
be unforgettable
and for the night's most nominated
artists maren morris and chris stapleton
they're making it a date night to
remember with their booze
[Music]
what is it like sharing the stage with
your husband for this special event
i'm so excited because typically i'm
trying to find him in the crowd
if i'm on stage performing just so i
like have somebody
that i can make eye contact with and now
it's like super easy to find him because
he's on stage with me yeah girl he's
going right beside of you i'll love it
marin and her husband ryan hurd are
performing their duet chasing after you
it's his first time taking the acm stage
i don't know if that adds pressure or
takes it off but i don't feel very much
right now
marin's nominated for six awards so is
chris
and get this he's also performing with
his spouse
and backup singer morgan
[Music]
now there is one category where chris
and marin are up against each other
song of the year
queen of the acms miranda lampert is
also in the running
and she'll be kicking off country
music's biggest party performing her
collab with l king
baby
what's the case for the performance now
obviously elle's pregnant
yeah well i just have to drink for two
so that's more fun for me
we were on the set of the music video
and let me tell you these ladies
sure know how to have fun
miranda will hit the stage for a second
time with singer-songwriters john
randall and jack
ingram
it's pretty stripped down right yes it's
us in our guitars yeah they're stripped
down as you can get yeah without being
stripped down
the 37 year old is the most nominated
female artist in the show's history
and nabbed five more nods this year for
a career total of 68
she's won 34 times the most of any
artist
i also love a red carpet moment with you
and your hubby brendan
well he loves it he knows all about it
yeah he loves getting glammed he's all
glam
he's all he's all already picking out
his jacket no way
that's fun though he's great at it so
he's just
happy to be there with me and let me do
my thing and then we gotta go home and
resume life
now for a couple categories to keep an
eye on starting with
single of the year the ladies are
finally getting their spotlight
from marin to miranda to mickey
the girls are dominating the acn's
let's go girls for the first time ever
all single of the year nominations
feature
a female artist miranda lambert marin
morris
gabby barrett carly pierce and ingrid
andrus
ingrid recently reacted to the news with
e.t
i was pumped i'm not gonna lie i was
like yes
finally like because i have been
listening to a lot of the women in that
category for years
and have heard amazing songs by them
representing the category as the
youngest nominee
is 21 year old gabby barrett who is
already a winner for new female artist
of the year
[Music]
when the former american idol star was
nominated for the same category last
year
she told et what a win would mean to her
it sounds really cliche like when people
are like oh that's like your dreams
coming true but it's so serious because
as an artist these are things at least
for me
so when i was younger i wanted i've been
watching the atms for years since i was
younger
as well as others too so it would mean
a ton and i would put it on my shelf and
get this
if gabby does take home single of the
year she'll become the fourth artist to
win that category
and new artist at the same time the
first three were clint black
leanne rimes and gabby's idol sister
gary underwood
the single of the year category could
also put carly pierce into the history
books
alongside lee bryce as the fourth male
female duet to win the
[Music]
hope category are happy now carly opened
up to e.t
about being recognized i don't know that
it sunk in
and i don't know that it's going to sink
in i think that that's
why it's just make everything
so special when you work so hard for
something that i hope they never sink in
carly is also nominated for female
artist of the year
up against one of her besties kelsey
ballerini
i'm not going to win that award i mean
listen i'm really practical
i'm really practical it's it's a gift
that i guess my parents gave me
um i being nominated is is
plenty and i'm very very honored to be
in that category
and it is not my year to win ashley
mcbride also has a hat in the ring
for female artist of the year when i
look at
the thumbnails of the women in that
category and i see my face next to those
faces
i laugh because it almost seems it still
seems kind of
unbelievable but here we are and we
can't forget about the super group
the high women randy carlisle marin
morris amanda shires and natalie hempby
could become the first all-female group
to win
for group of the year now talk about
girl power
yes the ladies are representing tonight
but sadly
not in the entertainer of the year
category case in point
so could thomas rhett be in for a repeat
good lord we have a tie for entertainer
of the year the first artist
tonight to receive the entertainer of
the year award thomas rhett
tied with tiara tonight as entertainer
of the year carrie underwood i like to
share with people
so um i just think it's it's just really
great that you know
of course it's 20 20. nothing is going
to be like normal
my heart is is racing so hard right now
it's i just saw carrie in the hallway
actually and i
i don't know what to say from the first
acm entertainer of the year ty
to carrie underwood becoming the first
woman to take home the night's top prize
three different times last year's acm
awards
were historic while the cry pretty
superstar isn't nominated this year in
the coveted category
thomas is
if the 31 year old gets a repeat he'll
join an elite club of artists who've had
consecutive wins
over the past two decades including toby
keith
kenny chesney jason aldean and taylor
swift
this is something i've been working hard
on for so long could the third time be a
charm for chris stapleton
yes yes is the answer i am shocked every
single time anybody gives me anything
that is an award the kentucky native and
leading male nominee
has been nominated in the entertainer of
the year category twice before new songs
playing shows staying on the road and
and doing stuff for the fans is the most
important thing in the business
well luke combs hard work has earned him
an entertainer of the year nomination
just two years after walking away with
the newcomer's top prize
get the home world singing
[Music]
if recent history is any indication this
could be eric church's year the
seven-time acm winner is
fresh off a thrilling performance at the
super bowl and last november
he picked up the entertainer of the year
trophy at the cma awards
and rounding out the category for the
night's highest honor
luke bryan
[Music]
the star who just before last year's
acms told us this
i had my first covet test because of the
acms
won't be in attendance this year after
testing positive for covid19
so if he does win his third acm's
entertainer of the year title
he'll be celebrating in quarantine as a
party of one
while luke is riding solo the acms will
be celebrating its most diverse group of
nominees in history
starting with our hostess with the
mostest mickey guyton
as a woman as a black woman it is such
an
honor that people are giving me this
opportunity to be heard
and to and to hopefully incite change
mickey made history at last year's acms
as the first black female artist to take
the stage
and perform her own song and this year
the new mom
is breaking barriers again she's one of
four black nominees
the most ever at one time
[Music]
the 37 year old was up for new female
artist of the year
but got beat out by former idol
contestant gabby barrett
as for new male artist of the year
that award went to jimmy allen who
became the very first black artist to
win in that category
congratulations jimmy
stop playing representation is super
important
it's kind of hard to tell a young black
kid you can be a country artist
when they don't see anything you know
so it's cool to have that
he got winner john legend nabbed his
first acm nod
for his duet with carrie underwood she
will also be a part of history
alongside gospel great cece winans
[Music]
who's performing at the acms for the
first time
kane brown won video of the year
worldwide beautiful by kane brown
making him the first black solo artist
to take that honor
and he's up for another big award you
know if you do take home the album of
the year award you will be the first
black artist to do so
in acm history i never even knew that
until today if it happens then
i don't know i'll probably be speechless
the 27 year old will also be taking the
stage at the award show to perform with
chris young
and you can bet kane's wife caitlin will
be watching with their 17-month old
kingsley
she's on the move right now honey she is
probably keeping you very busy she's a
bruiser
she's going to i feel like she's
hopefully she's going to be an athlete
but she uh
she's at that mode right now where she
loves seeing people get hurt and i'll
just act like it hurts and she'll just
[Music]
and when he's not loving life as a girl
dad cain's getting pumped
literally to go on tour this fall dude
you're looking buff these days
everyday workout how do these other moms
beat me
how does it feel knowing that you are
going to be hitting the road again kind
of nervous
i hope i don't forget any lyrics or
anything like that hopefully
i don't know kane will be hitting 35
cities
on his blessed and free tour and is
making history as the first country
artist
ever to play all 29 nba arenas
that's so cool i mean because you're a
ball player yourself yeah i love
basketball so we're trying to make it a
thing where like i play
at least one person from each team no
way
so hence the reason why you're hitting
the gym too yeah hopefully i can get a
10-day contract or something
e.t live is counting down to the hcm
awards and you know
pink is no stranger to country music
she's nominated tonight with keith urban
and she's not the only pop star making a
mark
pink arrived on the nashville scene in
2016
when she collaborated with kenny chesney
in the song setting the world on fire
[Music]
it earned her her first acm nomination
since then she's recorded with chris
stapleton and keith urban
and now her latest with keith one too
many scored her
another nod for music event of the year
and despite her global superstar status
pink is a country fan girl too not
missing the opportunity to snap a few
picks with the biggest names in country
john legend scored his first acm
nomination
the 42 year old was up for video of the
year for his duet with carrie underwood
[Music]
but he ended up losing to kane brown who
he actually
just collaborated with last year on the
powerful ballad
last time i say sorry
[Music]
gwen stefani has taken the country world
by storm
teaming up with her fiance blake shelton
the 51
year old has two number one country
songs under her belt
[Applause]
[Music]
while the two lovebirds are used to
making the acm awards their own
date night this year will be even more
special
just one year after making their acm
performance debut with happy anywhere
the newly engaged couple received a nod
for music event of the year for nobody
but
you while the two were beat out by carly
pearson lee bryce
it's not lost on blake how meaningful
this moment is
to share with his fiancee i can't
believe that
i get to be nominated for awards with my
best friend you know
and it was just one of those moments
it's like how do you get
so blessed and so lucky you know so uh
it was it's unbelievable i mean i don't
know what our chances are to win that
thing
but you know if we don't win it's we'll
know it's rigged
[Laughter]
and you know we love a good throwback
check out blake at the acms in the early
2000s
how's my does my mullet look good man i
can't tell you crap about my outfit
in honor of that curly mullet mr shelton
kicks off et's look at when we
first met some of your favorite country
stars
you never forget your first tour and
keith urban will always be the one that
gave that to me
so i'll be indebted to him forever
everyone asks me do you really love
country music and you know i didn't move
to nashville for the cheap rant
you know i've been playing it all my
life
where do you take this to work where do
you put it at home how what are you
gonna do i don't know
i haven't thought about that i don't
even have a fireplace but
i'll figure it out
luke grew up working on the family
peanut farm he
got his country music start writing
songs and he had zero
shame about being star struck it's also
fun when you get to come here and be uh
be here with big stars and
i mean you know i'm seeing heidi klum
and usher yeah our e.t
vault is filled with priceless vintage
moments with our favorite country
artists
hey y'all this is thomas anytime you put
nelly and florida georgia line together
there's gonna be some pretty girls in a
cool car and a good time i'm better than
you i'm just like
living in every moment
i'm carrie underwood i am 21 and i'm
from chicago oklahoma i'm a t-shirt and
jeans kind of girl so i'm ready for
somebody to get a hold of me and
tell me what to wear and what to do so
carrie got her start as a contestant on
american idol
the college student had flown on a plane
for the first time
to get to hollywood three months later
carrie underwood
has any of this sunk in yet no not at
all
it's just been a complete whirlwind it's
just been crazy
it's hard to believe that just a few
years ago kane was working at fedex
and posting his songs on social media
now he's 27
married and has a 17 month old daughter
kingsley
it's crazy i started in my bathroom i
grew up with nothing
and i'm just you know glad that i can
support myself now
[Music]
you can guest star on any disney channel
show past or present what would it be oh
my gosh hannah montana
all day every day that was my show
say what kelsey was just 14 when she
went to her first audition at a record
label
at the time an exec told her quote
there's already a taylor swift
that slot is taken and speaking of tay
before
new male artist of the year winner jimmy
allen was famous he landed a role in her
commercial
it feels like a perfect night to dress
up like hipsters but the 34 year old's
road to stardom wasn't easy
at one point he was homeless and lived
in his car and in 2011
jimmy made it to hollywood week on
american idol it would lead me back to
you
but got cut before the top 24. now
[Music]
i got into country music because of my
daddy all he listened to is country
music i wouldn't be here without my
[Music]
father
gotta love a good flashback all right so
jimmy allen is this year's
acm new male artist of the year yes this
guy right here
and another american idol alum took it
for the ladies
i'm here to let you know that gabby
barrett you are the winner
of the acm best new female artist of the
year
oh what a special moment right there and
get this
gaby's hit the good ones went number one
on billboard's country airplay chart
the day she got that news and we'll sure
have plenty of good ones to talk about
after tonight's acm see what i did there
you can watch the show on cbs or
paramount plus and then
come back right here on et live for our
post show
for a complete breakdown of all the
biggest moments plus behind the scenes
scoop
enjoy the show
you